good morning nation my name is Evan
Carmichael my one word to believe as I
believe that entrepreneurs will solve
all of the world's major problems so to
help you on your journey today's message
is it doesn't matter what your mom
thinks over to you you get unhappy if
you for many years before I wrote the
power of now and it became successful I
was basically a failure in the eyes of
the world so he's already almost 50 and
what has he achieved my mom said you
have thrown away your life you had so
many possibilities in your life you
walked out of graduate school in
Cambridge why did you walk out of there
you my mum and many other people said
this person has failed in life he has no
job he has no insurance policies nothing
no pension plan just almost nothing in
the bank failure and then a few years
later people bought the path now and
became a best seller or a big success
okay if I had arrived my identity at
that time from what the world was
telling me or my mind would have told me
if I have been listening to my mind I
would have been very unhappy and I
didn't so I was fine because my identity
wasn't derived from that anymore and
fortunately even when in the eyes of the
world I suddenly became a success I
don't want to derive my identity from
that it's a cheap substitute for who I
really am so I'm not I don't see I don't
arrive but the satisfaction it comes is
a satisfaction that the work that's
happening the teaching that's happening
is transforming people's lives that's
very satisfying I don't get any personal
satisfaction though because it's not I
don't feel it as this separately
used it it would be great that support
of your mom of your parents of your
friends of your family of your community
to do whatever it it doesn't want to do
but there is support shouldn't be
reflexively she go I was doing around
like if your mom says that this is the
right idea many cannot give ability you
know when you're growing up you know
when you're five years old okay dear mom
you know to do what she said you get a
shovel right with how old are you now
like at some point you decide this is my
life and I was loved to have a support
of my parents and I had the support of
my parents wrote but I was doing this
great but if you don't have the support
I was off point to decide that you're
not oh you did to say that you want to
do a great is going to be four years old
and still listening to your parents and
what they see for you and a lot of times
especially a parent and kind of love
right they want you to be successful
they want you to have a great life they
just want you to do it on their terms
the way that they see success may not be
lined up with how you see success and so
they may not be the ones telling you
that you suck and you never be anything
to compare and feel like that to which
does all of the story but most of the
time it's out of love it's out of my
duty be successful you just have
different views of what that looks like
and at some time you have to decipher
this in my life
I mean the thing that I want to do and
if you judge your self words based only
off of the results but you're never
going to be happy you're never going to
feel valuable right and so I look at my
youtube videos I look at this channel
look at what everything to you guys I
love everything that has developed a
process this is why it's so important if
you love the process of the work and not
just the results it's not just about a
to know subscribers right it's my Golson
in the year have 1 million subscribers
to see if we hit it's not just about
hitting a billion on Twitter which my
lifetime goal right I want to have a big
impact that one
reach appealing entrepreneurs if I can
do that and has we've done half a
percent impact in their life all the
things that they're going to go up and
make is going to be insane I'm marveling
at small tiny piece in your success but
let's button that number because you can
have a goal you can have a target and
say I want to really reach this thing
I'll do anything to get there you won't
do anything and you shouldn't do
anything if you looking for she doesn't
do something you don't like for so long
it's going to do the work that Jerry
Seinfeld tortured you can endure the
work that you love the torture that is
love the process is more important than
hitting a goal I was asked I'm going to
do a big target version to do
subscribers and I don't know like I do
it more for you guys that's for me right
we did one we did a live stream in half
a million and I haven't done any one
since we caught under the review of the
channel which is awesome but once we
kick the milestone it's a great target
to go and read but then it's in the past
I kind of own live the past I want to
keep moving folk we got more work to do
we've got more lives of change it's the
process it's not just hitting a million
subscribers I can do that a lot faster
and a lot means you're doing other
things you know if I was if I was
bashing entrepreneurs bashing
celebrities seeing all the negative
things about them that would have to
draw a lot more attention that would get
a lot more subscribers it's kind of the
sad state of humans would rather attack
somebody than embrace it and learn from
them we'd rather escape from a life that
we don't like as opposed to trying to
build the life that we do like and
that's fine but I don't want to do that
I would never be great at that I don't
like bashing people I don't want it to
the negative sides of everybody
everybody has a negative side someone I
want to put out to the world
and so my only goal is I want to even
going to describe no to anything I came
to get there those are the kinds of
things that we'll be doing when that
degree
and I should never get to that goal
which is not who I am
because I don't enjoy the process and so
not everything is going to be amazing
there's a lot of correct we have to deal
with as an entrepreneur but if you just
make it about this goal and just hitting
that mark did you never going to get
there and you have to really focus on
whether you're right or whether you're a
singer whether you're a dancer whether
yours youtuber whatever it is your
software developers enjoy running code
you have to enjoy the process of
figuring things out and solving the
problems and not just hitting a revenue
target I think you can do that you can
tie yourself word into the work saying
I'm proud of this saying that I made
even if nobody else likes it
this has been a lot of videos that I put
up that you've got time to like seven
kids I'm so proud of it
I still love them I was still like I'm
so happy because I've made that video I
think it's great it's genius
but even worse so it's great so it's
good if our observed amount of people
good for me and a select few can't build
a business around this but I don't feel
bad about myself for creating a series
us was a sticker with a luminescent
great piece of content insanely proud of
it
and I think as long as you were insanely
proud seeing the world it worked for me
and some of the minutes and some of them
are gonna miss most of the goodness
failed wing boards you would be a
success
if you're proud of work than the hustle
you putting in daily then you not just
get more self-worth for yourself and
feel better about what we're doing every
day but eventually just stick with it we
go degrees in amazing businesses I'll
have a big impact on the rest of the
world
so the question today is I'm curious
does or did your mom support you in what
you're doing right now these dumb comes
below I was doing two people cook
trailer to share discuss on terms thank
you so much for picking up a cup of my
book your one word and take you that
awesome exciting
take sheriffing so
to your Twitter I love the joy on your
phrase thank you so much and support and
flora enjoyment so thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you so
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso I will keep
egos
every pursuit no matter how glamorous it
may seem no matter how exciting you are
it feels to you no matter how much you
feel like you were born to do it comes
with a [ __ ] sandwich and so the question
is not what do I love the question is
what do I love so much that I don't mind
eating the [ __ ] sandwich that comes
along with that thing so for me in my
life
writing is the thing that I love and the
[ __ ] sandwich was the 7 years that I was
not getting published and that I was
coming home for my job as a diner
waitress as a bartender as an au pair as
a somebody who worked in flea markets as
a cook and I was coming home tired and
smelling like other people's french
fries and sitting down and doing my real
job which was to write and then to go to
the mailbox the next day and get another
rejection letter and then say joist
illusion is because this [ __ ] sandwich
ha ha ha ha
ready you know and I did still want to
do it and now even as somebody who makes
their living as a writer there's no end
to the [ __ ] sandwiches it's like oh
hello horrible review in prominent
newspaper that's your [ __ ] sandwich
today was you still want to do this work
yeah yeah I still do still worth it like
Hello awful comment on social media from
somebody who thinks you're a pile of oh
yeah you know I just have like chosen
every possible way that they can just
cannot get it out of their system fast
enough how much disregard they have for
your entire life yes still want to do
this thing yeah I still want to do it
you know so that's the question because
if the first time you encounter this
should sandwich your like well this this
isn't worth it then that's not the thing
you're supposed to be doing yeah and
there are plenty of things in life that
that I have run into the ship sandwich
and I've been like so not worth it so
not worth it like this is now I don't
want to do this like whatever the bed
alleged benefits of this thing yes might
be no down soul cycle no you know like I
know it's probably really good for me
but I feel like throwing up right now is
too hard come on you'll not be seeing me
here again you know like I'm and I love
my sister's is soul cycle I just don't
like feeling like I'm gonna throw up
when I exercise so it's not for me you
know and and so that's the question so
if you go into this thing thinking if I
follow my bliss and I live my dream and
I
stand in my truth and everything will be
great it doesn't mean everything will be
great
it just means at the end of the day when
you check in with yourself and you go in
the end on the balance is this still
better than not doing it and the answer
is still yeah this thing's still better
than not doing it then you're on the
right path I knew I wanted to be in the
skate industry I loved skating too much
I wanted I wanted to be in it I didn't
know if I would make a living as a
professional but I was going to be I was
devoted to skateboarding so I refinanced
my house and took all the money and
started a skateboard company which seems
like the stupidest thing in the world to
do when skating's done but it was
exactly what what I wanted to do I
wanted to be a company owner and be
behind the scenes I quickly sponsor and
and started and for about three years
struggled very very hard with my partner
and I we had pulled our mind together he
was a X pro skater as well and we just
we just did birdhouse and did whatever
we could to get by and all the team was
staying on my couch and literally like
wond changing diapers I'm like driving
you guys to these spots that they're
going to get arrested at because there's
no skatepark so they're going to go ride
schoolyards and it was such a strange
existence but but I loved it because it
was skateboarding it is exactly what I
wanted to do and so we really hunkered
down you know like I was I was living on
Taco Bell and peanut Barn jelly and Top
Ramen mmm probably three years for sure
but I didn't care because it was like I
still got to do what I love that's the
thing is that people think was a
struggle it's like well no because you
know I loved it too much I still got to
go skate and I had time to skate I
didn't have to go sit behind a computer
for eight hours and then hope I get time
to scan I've never really been
interested in living a balanced life you
know I don't I think balanced people
don't change the world first of all I
think balanced people don't really
follow a dream you know this doesn't
mean that you don't have
responsibilities like let's go to the
other part of this question how can you
have a family well sure you can have a
family and have you know but balance is
kind of like I feel like balance is like
a made-up word it's like invented by
corporations you know
to make their employees think that
they're happy you know it's like you got
this balance like you could work at
Microsoft you know or something here in
Seattle and not there's like 10
Microsoft people on the audience right
no disrespect to Microsoft particulars
Microsoft's Greg one out of every five
people I was Rihanna or some I guess
that's right you know and it's like you
know you got you got this thing and
maybe you love your job and if you love
your job that's great but I hear from a
lot of dissatisfied people I had some of
these big companies and they write in or
like I'm reading your blog for my
cubicle and like you know I had this
good job and I've got my health
insurance I've got free yoga every
Thursday but I'm not really you know
right I'm not really fulfilled so for me
I guess I'm much more just in that word
fulfilled like you know how can you live
a fulfilled life and you can live a
fulfilled life and still pay your bills
you know lots of creative people do it
lots of unconventional people do it and
I would say if anything it's actually
much more common now than it used to be
you know when I first started working
online you know 15 years ago I didn't
know a lot of other people who were
doing that you know my friends thought I
was selling drugs or something we were
well I would you know but they're like
online gambling or we know whatever our
parents have no idea how the internet
works and stuff but now it's it's much
more common so I don't really like the
word balance myself so what we'd like to
do is we want to replace the word like
living a balanced life is not the goal
the goal is living off a filled life